a key takeaway from life cycles is that
your application runs until Android
needs to free resources for something
else
that means it's best if we design
sunshine to continue to work well even
if the operating system has to close us
and the app no longer has weather data
one might ask this is the era of the
connected cloud why don't we just always
fetch the weather on demand do we really
need to worry about saving anything on
the device
well first user experience is important
when sunshine is launched we want our
users to be immediately greeted with
up-to-date hot off the API weather
information and not a blank screen the
faster people can use an app the more it
will be used for something like weather
people want the details immediately
available second using any radio is
detrimental to the battery life of the
device especially the cellular radio
storing the weather data rather than
fetching at each time saves battery life
and that leads to happier users third
there are many users on metered data
plans or users may be roaming when they
want to use sunshine all those
unnecessary data fetches can add up
fourth if you're running a web service
for your application you'll be highly
motivated to reduce the server load and
network bandwidth fifth there are still
lots of places that don't have a network
connection available constantly one of
the prime advantages of having a mobile
app is being resistant to bad or
non-existent Network conditions sixth
and finally you never know where a user
will want to use your app although our
weather API currently doesn't support
outer space locations being smart about
the way we use system resources is key
to making sunshine a good Android
citizen as conscientious developers we
strive to make all our apps adhere to
these principles by minimizing network
activity and working seamlessly between
offline and online states we persist
data in sunshine to make it both a
better experience for users while making
it use less network and battery
resources